هناك الكثير من التقنيات ، لذلك أعتقد أنه لا توجد حدود.
ستكون جذابة
يسعدني أن أكون قادرًا على إظهار ما كنت أمارسه أثناء الرحلات
عندما تكون هناك
[موسيقى]
اسمي يو إم غون
يستخدم التتبع لقب Kee Gurney
في وقت مبكر الآن ، متخصص في الرحلات
في الخارج ، أعمل من خلال العروض الآن.
على وجه الخصوص ، الملك هو فأس السندات الذي أقوم به ، آلة الرادو في المستقبل
الجسم
على ما يبدو ، التايكوندو لديها ركلات وتجريد
لأنه يستخدم ركلة التايكوندو
نعم
يقال إن التايكوندو هو أفضل شكل من أشكال فنون القتال الكورية التقليدية.
أظن
أعتقد أن وجبات الغداء الكورية و p مضمنة.
بدأت التايكوندو عندما كنت صغيرا جدا ، عندما كنت في الخامسة من عمري.
لقد كنت أفعل ذلك منذ أن كنت صغيرًا جدًا ، لذلك وقعت في حب سحر التايكوندو دون أن أدرك ذلك.
بعيدا عن المكان
أما لماذا بدأت ، فقد كنت أواصل التايكوندو ، لكن في المنتصف
لا يوجد شيء خيالي
لقد انتهى هذا الفن القتالي اللامع الذي يمكن القيام به بالتزامن مع التايكوندو
لذلك وجدت تريكي.
ما هي الركلة الفنية؟ 140 إزالة الشعر
لقد بدأت في السنة الثانية من المدرسة الإعدادية
عندما بدأت تلك الركلة ، بدأت أيضًا بالميدالية الفضية ، وأنا
الأمر ليس صعبًا كما تعتقد
[موسيقى]
الناس الذين يمارسون الرياضة في كوريا
هل يمكنك العيش عليها؟
لم تكن حياة جيدة ، لكنها تغيرت قليلاً الآن
إنه لأمر جيد ، حتى لو كان أصدقائي حسودًا ، فأنا أفعل ما أريد القيام به
أردت أن أكون ناجحًا ، لكني أحسدك على هذا النحو
تغير قليلا
[موسيقى]